Aufbruch in die Dunkelheit vor der Küste
Tunesiens Oberzeller und sein Team
nehmen uns mit es ist ein Einsatz von
dem Sie bereits wissen sie werden heute
Nacht wieder viele Männer und Frauen
aufgreifen die voller Hoffnung in ein
Boot nach Europa gestiegen sind
wir fanden parada schauen ob etwas auf
dem ECHO erscheint und dann fahren wir
dahin und wenn wir Migranten sehen dann
stoppen wir sie
es dauert nicht lange und sie entdecken
ein kleines Fischerboot
12 Personen an Bord die Versuche zu
fliehen
vergeblich der Ton von Beginn an rau die
Beamten packen Schlagstöcke aus drohen
als die Passagiere aufspringen setzt
euch hin
in jüngster Zeit mehren sich die
Vorwürfe die Küstenwache würde die
Migranten in Lebensgefahr bringen deren
Schiffe absichtlich Kentern lassen das
beobachten wir in dieser Nacht nicht
wohl aber eine Konflikt geladene
gereizte Stimmung
es ist nicht so dass sie nicht gerettet
werden wollen wenn Sie in einer
gefährlichen Situation sind Sie rufen
uns um Hilfe aber wenn wir dann
versuchen Sie an Land zurückzubringen
dann wären sie sich sagen sie wollen
lieber sterben
lernen
und es werden immer mehr erzählt uns
Salalah der den Job seit 30 Jahren macht
die Fluchtursachen nehmen zu Konflikte
Verfolgung wirtschaftliche Not treiben
sie über das Meer wie diesen Tunesier
der sein Gesicht nicht zeigen will
ich will ein besseres Leben in Tunesien
gibt es noch nicht mal mehr Getreide
oder Brot und von solchen Problemen hört
man in Italien nichts
er und Sizilien sind nah mehr als 50.000
migranten sollen seit Jahresbeginn dort
angekommen sein noch viel mehr haben es
versucht gut 1000 € müssen Sie für einen
Platz auf einem Boot auftreiben das oft
dann auch noch sehr untauglich ist
einmal Wasser zu spät die Menschen
trieben bereits im Wasser als er ankam
das hat mich lange beschäftigt und es
tat mir sehr leid dass ich nicht alle
retten konnte
22 Menschen konnten wir in dieser Nacht
helfen aber sechs oder sieben sind
ertrunken
das Sterben im Mittelmeer und die Angst
vor einer flüchtlingskrise führen in
Europa zu einem neuen werben um Tunesien
dessen Präsident Kaiser Jet bekommt nun
viel Besuch von hochrangigen
Politikerinnen und Politikern die den
tunesischen Staatschef bis vor kurzem
eher gemieden haben denn sayette ist ein
Auto Grad gestützt auf einen starken
Sicherheitsapparate reißt er immer mehr
Macht an sich verfolgt und verhaftet
seine politischen Gegner all das hindert
Europa nicht daran eine wie es heißt
neue Partnerschaft mit Tunesien
auszuloten auch die deutsche
Innenministerin reist an und kaiserjet
freut sich über die Aufmerksamkeit aus
dem Ausland
lassen Sie uns diese Situation gemeinsam
lösen aber ich möchte auch noch mal
wiederholen Tunesien kann seine eigenen
Grenzen schützen
wir weigern uns ein Aufnahmeland für
Migranten zu sein
sieht sich in einer starken Position
beim Aushandeln eines neuen
migrationspakts und so sind im Angebot
etwa mehr arbeitswieser für tunesische
Fachkräfte in Deutschland erklärt
Innenministerin Faeser beim Besuch einer
deutsch-tunesischen Jobagentur das
nordafrikanische Land solle dafür bei
Abschiebungen besser kooperieren und
mehr Geld etwa für Grenzposten und
Ausrüstung bekommen
es sind längst nicht nur tunesia die
nach Europa wollen viele Migranten
kommen aus Westafrika und jüngst aus den
Konfliktgebieten im Sudan Tunesien wird
mehr und mehr zum Transitland in den
Küstenstädten harren sie aus bis sie auf
einem der flüchtlingsbote unterkommen
wir leben hier schlafen auf Kartons und
wenn es regnet unter einem Baum
so wie ihr den Ukrainern helft die vor
einer Katastrophe fliehen solltet ihr
auch uns aufnehmen wir sind alle
Menschen und haben alle das Recht zu
leben
wir sind so müde und bereit sobald es
geht über das Meer zu fahren das ist
egal ob wir hier sterben oder da draußen
die Verzweiflung wächst und so auch die
Zahl der Migranten die oberste aller und
seine Kollegin aufgreifen im Auftrag
auch von der EU die finanzielle
Unterstützung dafür wird nun noch mal um
mehr als 100 Millionen Euro aufgestockt
die Nacht ist vorüber Männer Frauen
Kinder drängen sich auf dem Hauptschiff
der Küstenwache und werden zurück an
Land gebracht
salaweis einige von ihnen sieht er wohl
bald wieder
wir waren jetzt die ganze Nacht zusammen
die ihr selbst gesehen habt die meisten
der Migranten haben es schon fünf oder
sechs mal versucht
wir greifen sie immer wieder auf und
dann versuchen Sie es wieder
montieren zwar die Motoren ab doch die
Migranten finden ihren Weg immer wieder
zu groß die Not auf dem afrikanischen
Kontinent zu groß die Sehnsucht nach
einem besseren Leben in Europa
unterdessen stapeln sich am Ufer die
Boote die die Küstenwache Nacht für
Nacht zurück ans Festplatte